[Music]
gonna start off with jennifer in los
angeles hi jennifer welcome to the
ramsey show
hello thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
okay so i am planning on moving out of
state from i'm from bakersfield actually
moving out of state for work and i have
a home here i'm on baby step six working
on paying this house off
um
the market's really high
right now um so
if i sell my house i don't know where i
should park my equity or if it's a good
idea to just rent my house out
because when i do move i will be renting
for a year until i figure out where i
actually want to live
so that's my question cool
so uh why are you moving you're getting
a new job where
well
i'm a nurse and there's just a lot of
restrictions out here i've wanted to
leave the state of california for a very
long time and um
i spent the last eight months working
out in texas and i really enjoyed it
so so texas here we come huh
possibly or tennessee we are somewhere
between there we hear that story a lot
yeah we we are in tennessee we hear it a
lot yeah so it's very cool well good uh
well what i would do if i woke up in
your shoes which is by the way how i
answer questions here is if i knowing
what i know if i woke up just like you
what would i do i would sell the house
okay okay a lot of reasons the reason is
um number one like you said the market's
hot
and it's a possible high point to i
don't know it probably is going to go
higher
long term but right now you can get
really really good money out of it you
can sell it really easily
and you're going to pay no income tax on
the growth
okay did you make are you going to make
a profit of more than 250 000 no uh it
will be close to i think after closing
costs and everything around 100 000.
okay then you'll make all of that
hundred without any taxes on it single
person married filing jointly is 500 000
you can make on your home uh mary a
single person can make up to 250
profit on your home over what you paid
for it
and uh with no taxes at all and i would
take that and i would put it in a money
market account
move to texas tennessee wherever it is
start my nursing career once you decide
you're going to put down roots in that
location
then i would start looking at purchasing
but long-distance landlording is not a
good plan
uh it's very difficult it's uh always
laughing i got a bunch of real estate i
love real estate but long distance
landlording is always a good way to get
somebody to change their harley oil in
your living room
and so it's many
so many market accounts and not like a
mutual fund unless you're gonna leave it
alone five years i wouldn't use a mutual
fund yeah but i i think you're going to
move somewhere and a year from now
you're going to start getting an itch to
buy
if you've decided to stay in that city
okay does that sound right to you
yes it does now i have one more question
from that would if i because i'm
considering going and getting my
master's degree and i don't
i'm sorry why
yeah just to um ex like i guess grow my
options as far as nursing goes um
because i would like to get into like
management leadership administration
okay that's a good why
good well i would use some of this money
to pay for that then and let me just
tell you master's degrees are priced all
over the map do not overpay for this
little two-year degree
absolutely i just plan not to i plan
this in as little as possible because
where you went to school will not
determine whether you get hired
okay no one hires people based on famous
colleges that's absolute bs put out by
famous colleges
yes jennifer i'd ask are you positive
that you need a master's to get those
leadership positions
i'm not positive but i feel like them i
feel like i've been trying to like apply
because i've been a nurse for a lot
almost 12 years and i want to get out of
bedside nursing and i just it seems like
they want that degree sure well again
it's a great why but i want you to go
from i feel like it seems like to i
absolutely know that there's a higher
percentage chance much higher percentage
chance if i have it versus not and the
reason i say this is because you have an
opportunity here to get in as you move
into a new place you've got 12 years
experience very talented and you express
the desire to lead and begin to lead up
and to show
leadership that you're leading being
that 360 degree leader as our friend
john maxwell wrote a book on um i i
would just look into that and if it's
the best way
then then do it if it's the only way do
it if it's not either one of those two
then uh hustle save yourself some time
and money on that master's degree
sometimes people have an illusion that a
degree is necessary for something when
it's not
that's ken's point and so really dig
into it start talking to people in the
role that you want to be in and find out
if they how many of them actually have
master's degrees and how much of a
barrier it is to not have one
so um because sometimes it's just like i
don't feel secure i don't feel confident
and so i'm going to get this degree and
that's going to make me confident not
really
you hire a lot of leaders dave we'll
just put this to the test i don't
master's degree is nice you respect it
but that doesn't
factor into the decision
not not at all i mean two percent five
percent whatever i mean i mean a
master's in business is a great mba is a
great it's a great degree it's a good
field to study
but and we've got some of them on the
team um and they're they're smart
they're good it's all all great but i'd
hire them for that
i heard them because i could see in
their eyes and in their mannerisms and
in the interview process that they were
going to be able to lead people yeah
and that is usually not taught in the
classroom by the way
so
but you've got to get that built out